PRIYANKA: Hi, I'm
Priyanka [INAUDIBLE],,
and this is AI
Simplified, where we
will take the journey
from data sets
all the way to deployed
machine learning models.
No matter which service
you offer today,
it is crucial to use the data
you have to make predictions
so you can improve your apps
and the user experience.
But most teams have
varying levels of machine
learning expertise, ranging from
novice all the way to experts.
To accelerate AI innovation,
you need a platform
that can help you build
expertise for those novice
users, and provide a seamless
and flexible environment
for those experts.
This is where
Vertex AI comes in.
It provides tools for every
step of the machine learning
workflow across
different model types,
for varying levels of
machine learning expertise.
Before we take a
look at Vertex AI,
though, let's understand
the typical machine
learning workflow.
After defining your prediction
task, the first thing you do
is ingest the data, analyze
it, and then transform it.
Then you create and
train the model.
Evaluate that model for
efficiency and optimization.
And then deploy it
to make predictions.
Now, with Vertex AI, you get
a simplified machine learning
workflow in one central place.
Ingestion, analysis,
and transforming
is really all about
data preparation.
And you do that using managed
data sets within Vertex AI.
You have tools to
create the data set
by importing your data using
the console, or just the API.
You can also label and
annotate the data right
from within the console.
For model training,
you have two options--
AutoML or custom.
With varying machine learning
expertise on the team,
for some use cases such as
images or videos, text files,
and tabular data,
AutoML works great.
With AutoML, you don't need to
write any of the model code.
Vertex AI will take
care of finding
the best model for that task.
And for other use
cases where you
would like more control over
your model's architecture,
use custom models.
Now, custom models are great
for frameworks and architectures
and code that you want
to write yourself.
So this works great for
TensorFlow or PyTorch code.
Once that model is trained,
you have the ability
to assess that model, optimize
it, and even understand
the signals behind your
model's predictions.
And you do that
with explainable AI.
And explainable AI lets you
dive deeper into your model
and understand which factors
are playing a role in defining
what that model is predicting.
Once you're happy
with the model,
you deploy it to an
endpoint to serve it
for online predictions using
the API or the console.
Now, this deployment includes
all the physical resources
and the scalable
hardware that's needed
to scale that model for lower
latency and online predictions.
You can, of course, use
the undeployed model
for batch predictions.
Once the model is
deployed, you can
get the predictions using
either the command line
interface, or the console
UI, or the SDK and the APIs.
At this point, you
might be wondering
how this looks in the
console and where to find it.
So let me give you a little
tour of the dashboard.
In the console, when
we click on Vertex AI,
we land on the
dashboard, where you
can see the recent data
sets, recent models,
and get predictions.
On the left, you have
all the steps that
are involved in the
machine learning workflow,
all the way from data
sets to predictions.
In the data sets, you can
create your data sets,
depending on the type of data
and your prediction task.
Supported data types include
image, tabular, text,
or videos.
If your prediction test doesn't
fall into one of these use
cases, don't worry.
You can still use Vertex AI
for your custom model training
and prediction.
Once you have
created a data set,
you can see it listed
in the data set list.
In the Notebook
section of the console,
you can create your
customized notebook instances
with the type of environment
and GPUs you want.
The Training tab, you can see
and create your training jobs.
The beauty is that you
can have one data set,
but you can train it
in different ways.
With AutoML, you can
train a high quality model
with minimal effort.
AutoML Edge for models that
are optimized for Edge devices.
And with the Custom
Training option,
you can train models
built with any framework,
via pre-built or
custom containers.
Pre-built containers
are available
for supported frameworks
such as TensorFlow, PyTorch,
scikit-learn, and XGBoost.
You provide your code
as a Python package.
The Custom Containers
option allows
you to train models built
with any framework or language
by putting your training
application code in a Docker
container, push it to
Container Registry,
and run training on Vertex.
You can accelerate the
training with GPUs,
and also apply
hyperparameter tuning.
In the Models tab, you
can see all the models
you have created.
Here, you can also import models
trained outside of Google Cloud
to serve it for online
and batch predictions.
In order to use a model, you
create an endpoint, which
brings us to our next step.
Creating an endpoint is
how you serve your models
for online predictions.
Each model can have
multiple endpoints.
Enter the compute resources
so your endpoint can
auto scale the resources
based on your traffic.
You can even split
traffic across endpoints
and send model logs
to Cloud Logging.
Once the model is live, we
can make predictions in the UI
or through the SDK.
In the Batch
Predictions tab, you
can make predictions
on the batch
of data from Cloud Storage.
This was a pretty
high-level overview
where we saw that Vertex AI
provides the tools to support
your entire machine learning
workflow from data management
all the way to predictions.
In the next episodes,
we will dive much deeper
into all of these steps and
build end-to-end machine
learning workflow.
In the meantime, let's
continue our discussion
in the comments below.
I'm excited to hear
all about your machine
learning use case and workflow.